organist von 5 stück daran scheiß oder
war das zu viel
12345 kommt auch noch ein ganz viele
pixel haben eine ganze welt wird
zerstört
richtig richtig cool hallo meine lieben
freunde und herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen mod vorstellung und zwar von der
picture modifikationen wie canon mit
sicherheit godzilla da kamen ja in
letzter zeit sehr viel nicht kritik aber
ich sag mal positive kritik zu diesem
film den ich auch sehr sehr geil fand
ich liebe godzilla und der film war echt
richtig geil und jetzt gibt's eine mod
die pixel heißt und das ganze ist quasi
godzilla ist er diese riesen eidechsen
ähnliches teil was irgendwie alles
kaputt macht und die zwei anderen teile
dann in dem neuen film besiegt diese
zwei anderen reptilien und dann
irgendwie doch die menschheit rettet und
alles mögliche
also richtig geil und das einzige was
wir hier brauchen ihr seht schon ein
ganzes inventars voll mit scheiße ihr
seht schon wenn wir hier im creative
mord im inventar sind und wir gehen
einfach mal eins nach rechts sehen wir
hier in form des sky also so ist der
richtige name dieser modifikation mit
vertrauen des kreises ist vom himmel
runter gefallen
oder halt pixlr und dann sehen wir hier
schon einen kompakt rob oakeshott place
in right click vanessa star und das das
einzige was zugefügt wird dazu wird ihr
noch empfohlen ja ein netter steine
karotten route dazu nehmen wir uns doch
einfach mal wieder montiert von amazon
partner so tief dass sie gern mal
richtig soll das ist nämlich das einzige
was wir brauchen im survival mode ist
das sehr sehr einfach zu machen wir
brauchen neuen rohes schweinefleisch in
kriegen wie ein kompakt rot pop shop und
jetzt zeige ich euch mal was man damit
alles machen kann und zwar ich mir schon
eine welt runtergeladen den download
finden link in not finde den download
link findet in der beschreibung ich
schäme mich jetzt einfach mal kurz rein
direkt in der mitte setzt jetzt das
teilen und die schon den sound gehört
da kommt aber so ein schweine grunzen
und wir jetzt einmal mit dem nettetaler
draufklicken wieder sein schwager grund
sein herz gehört und jetzt schaut was
passiert
pixie lott fliegt durch das gebäude die
ganzen blöcke prasseln auf die welt und
er macht alles kaputt bundes lag das
leid das leck ist legt jedenfalls seht
ihr hier schon diesen heftigen schweift
er in das gebäude rein gekracht ist
jetzt fliegt er hier runter überall sind
die blöcke verteilt das ist sehr sehr
krass also so wie gott zeller die haben
wir auch in der stadt alles möglich
kaputt gemacht ein großes lob an alle
katar in dem film godzilla geht auf
jeden fall rein das ist kein product
placement ich bekomme dann fix für aber
ich finde film einfach richtig cool
damit ihr das so ein bisschen hiermit
man vergleichen können wie das hier auch
stattfindet konzert fand ich so auf die
erde gekommen ja doch schon unserem
opfer hier eine coole kreuzung doch
schon also in seiner internet unserem
oder irgendwie so war sondern auf der
erde gelandet und alle systeme
geschlüpft und das lebt von atomenergie
und bla bla bla bla bla jedenfalls was
ziemlich unklug team sind das da oben
zusätzlich sollte man ihn auf den boden
setzen
da macht er nämlich erstens nicht so
viel kaputt und jetzt steckt als feste
steckte fest
damit steckten fest und jetzt sehen wir
gleich in die evolution und zwar ihr
seht es ist ein schweinekopf soll das
ganze darstellen moment da sehen wir
schon eine ziemliche vorne die augen
oder wo sind die augen nicht mal geht
alles kaputt was der so schön gebaut hat
kuckuck saß im auge und jetzt sehen wir
schon jetzt wird der körper
revolutioniert oder irgendwie so und
jetzt sehen wir hier ist das riesige
pixel auf das macht alles kaputt es
macht alles kaputt dieses pixel ist
einfach fakt baden dieses pixel also das
macht alles kaputt pixel pass mal auf
ihr ein bisschen ihre ganze welt ihr
deswegen hab ich mir extra seine welt
untergehen damit ihr seht was das für
eine zerstörungskraft hat diese
entwicklung zu kommen die ganzen block
ich kenne das du hast der tornado
modifikation die fliegen wirklich so rum
und prallen auch ab an den gebäuden
jetzt vielleicht sehen wir dass jetzt
gleich mal da das prallt so richtig auf
das cool also richtig runter da unten
sehen es auch die cola da richtig rund
und setzte sich danach wieder richtig
hin
das ist richtig richtig cool finde ich
richtig geil
und was macht er da dann macht er gerade
ein bisschen crazy sachen hier
ihr könnt übrigens wenn ihr das ist ein
bisschen schwierig wenn ihr direkt hier
moment wenn ihr direkt hier vor dem seit
ich weiß wir hier kurz dass ihr weg und
ihr ua der ist auch relativ schnell wenn
er direkt vor dem seitentrakt könnt ihr
nicht auf ihn drauf steigen
der hat jetzt auch grad fest jetzt kann
ich wieder laufen sondern ihr müsst ihr
ein bisschen unter dem sein und dann
müsst ihr recht ruhigen moment so dass
das ganze jetzt bin ich da drauf drücken
schiff zu verlassen
okay ich bin unter ihnen dass es stark
moment ich geh mal kurz hierhin sagt
jetzt bin ich mich auf seiner nase
ihr seht schon ich kann in pixel reiten
auf der nase und jetzt kann ich eine
karotte route nehmen und kann ihm sagen
kommen wir da hin oder kommen wir dahin
kommen genau hierhin kommen jetzt dreh
dich mal ein bisschen im kreis nehmen
cool cooler besser wenn man dann
wirklich diese ganz große ansicht hätte
von ganz oben auf pizza darauf nicht nur
auf einen selbst dass wir noch mal
richtig geil kann ich sagen geh mal
hierhin jetzt soll ich mal dahin gehen
blasig hierhin drehen
das ist richtig richtig cool l schiff
zum verlassen also shift einfach drücken
so und jetzt natürlich es ist eine
modifikation mit der man wirklich
einfach nur spaß hatte ich wollte
einfach nicht einfach vorstellen als
echte richtig richtig geiles einfach so
ein bisschen sonne wenn ihre welt habt
einfach kaputt machen damit das mal
richtig spaß
und jetzt kommt natürlich immer da ist
aber allein geflogen
jetzt kommt es natürlich wieder auf euch
an downloadlink und das alles in der
beschreibung ist aber noch nicht vorbei
ihr fragt euch bestimmt was passiert
denn wenn man davon mehreres bauen lässt
das machen wir jetzt mal ja gerade auf
der suche nach meinen ganzen hochhäusern
bei denen ich grad war und finde ich
einfach mal diese coole railway bahn das
ist ein richtig cooler solange krass
also wirklich ein lob an den bauer
dieser ganze sache
das ist sehr sehr sehr sehr geil auch
hier mit der brücke und so ist cool wenn
du traurig wenn ihr jetzt ein pixel
dahin kommen leider manchmal einfach so
hier sitzen wir hier noch einen damit
den mache ich sehe wie das jetzt mit dem
kometen läuft kommen jetzt nämlich von
irgendwo da da ist er schon
sonst bleibt ihr unteren kleben da sieht
jetzt doch mal schön mit dem abprallen
und jetzt evolution wie die sie ad hoc
oder kommt zwar mit zwei mann aufgeregt
ich weiß gar nicht oder doch noch zu dem
ich weiß es nicht ich weiß es nicht so
ich habe jetzt zwar die hochhäuser nicht
gefunden irgendwie weil die map ist
riesig diese riesig groß deswegen hab
ich mir gedacht ich setze jetzt einfach
hier nochmal hier setzt auch noch mal
einen rein
hier setzt jetzt einfach mal organist
von 5 stück daran weiß oder war das zu
viel
12345 kommt da ganz viele pixel haben
eine ganze welt wird zerstört
richtig richtig cool alles ganz ganz
viele leute fliegen denn dieses gebäude
rein und natürlichkeit alles irgendwie
so ein bisschen an den 11 september ist
jetzt auf jeden fall bot das ist so
krass hier guckt euch das mal an alles
zerfleddert einfach die kraft das ist
kann die ganze welt ist im eimer
alles wird ihr zerstört das ist richtig
krass und die sind richtig viele pixel
und die laufen rum und wollen wir eine
ganze welt kaputt machen
malta ist das gras oha ich würde mal
richtig gern meine meine skyscraper
jetzt hier wieder finden das ist nicht
einmal so ein bisschen hier guck mal
hier sind ja schon ein bisschen schnell
wieder
hier könnte man ja also wenn man jetzt
ganz witzig ist könnte man ja sagen hier
kommt da kommt der fünf stück hin
da kommt ein 23 dahin sind auch noch
welche da kommt 24 tätig eigentlich
keine ahnung die fliegen jetzt alle hier
rein und mein ganzes minecraft
hineinzulegen und ihr seht schon totale
zerstörung oh mein gott das ist doch
unglaublich guckt euch das mal an
überall liegen blöcke herum und diese
pixeln überall alter ich mache hat die
ganze zeit screenshot weil das einfach
unglaublich krass aussieht wie fliegen
überall blöcke herum
es hakt wieso aber das ist richtig
richtig krass weil die sich gerade hier
also evolution nieren oder wie das heißt
krass und diese pixel das schweben über
meiner stadt und laufen dann drüber und
alles mögliche und wo ist das
krass leute das ist unglaublich ich kann
die ganze noch mal betonen meine ganze
welt wird die zerstört überall fliegen
bäckerei wo ich hingucke fliegen
irgendwelche blöcke herum und alles wird
zerstört und viel zu viele pixel und mag
also ich würde euch auf jeden fall sagen
freude wenn es euch gefallen hat wenn
euch solche witzig modifikationen
gefallen und nicht immer etwas wohl
richtig coole sachen zu gewähren sondern
einfach mal sowas bescheuertes auch dann
zeigt sie mit einem daumen hoch
vielleicht schaffen wir die 3000 oder so
das wäre unglaublich cool dafür dass das
ist richtig geil hinten ist genau wie
beim block lang geflogen
richtig richtig cool downloadlink der
map und download link von der mod ist in
dem schreiben macht dafür ford 1972
alles super richtig richtig richtig
richtig geil finde ich richtig cool hier
alles und ich würde sagen freuen wir uns
in der nächsten mottoshow ich habe eines
geistig wieder gefunden ist auch egal
wie sie zunächst mal wieder reinartz gut
und scharf